with me now is glenn greenwald author of
the book
securing democracy and glenn you
said something rather extraordinary uh
to me uh to tucker last night you were
talking about the way
dianne feinstein and other powerful
politicians who are supposed
to be in charge of uh democratic
oversight of the nsa and their like
are actually under surveillance by these
agencies themselves
and so are actually scared of them
yeah i mean this has been going on since
basically the end of world war
ii when the national security state was
created
on purpose to be outside of the realm of
democratic accountability but at least
there the argument was
we need to do this to deter a threat
that no longer exists which is soviet
communism but
even then they were constantly
interfering in domestic politics j edgar
hoover had dossiers
on all kinds of american politicians
they were all petrified of him so he was
able to do what he want
when dwight eisenhower left after eight
years as the president
no leftist tea he chose one topic to
warn the country about which was
what he called the military-industrial
complex that it was growing so rapidly
that it was becoming more powerful
even than elected leaders and that was
before the vietnam war before 9 11 and
now before the hysteria
over january 6 and so you have these
agencies mark that
do whatever they want including
collecting information
on the members of congress who are the
only ones who can exercise oversight of
them and so you can see
why there's really no oversight at all
they do whatever they want and pose such
a great threat to democracy
but when when you're talking about the j
edgar hoover days
uh in fairness to those guys they
actually had to get into somebody's
apartment
and stick a bug in the wardrobe it's the
combination now of
uh technology and again this insane
huge number five million people with
with security clearances
that just means that any old low-level
bureaucrat can
can basically switch on his computer and
be
inside the emails of whoever he wants
i think that's a key point you know the
internet when it first emerged the idea
was it was going to be this
unprecedented tool of human liberation
it was going to enable us to communicate
without centralized corporate and state
power
and in fact the opposite has happened
which is it's been turned into
the greatest tool of coercion and
control
ever known in history because the nsa
secretly
which is what edward snowden came forth
to reveal to his fellow citizens
had decided to use it to spy on
everybody
and it really hasn't been reigned in
since then so you're exactly right it's
the ease with which
all of our activities that now take
place digitally especially after the
covet pandemic
can be collected and stored and
monitored and analyzed
and then weaponized with very little
safeguards
yeah basically they start from the
premise which is an orwellian premise
that they monitor
everyone it's universal a hundred
percent and then they pick and choose
the bits they need why is the left
uh at ease with this is it just because
they think well it will afflict
tucker carlson and our other enemies
and that's and that's more important
than any of the darker implications of
total control
you know it's bizarre i've worked on
this issue for 15 20 years it used to be
a more or less left-wing view
that the security state agencies
shouldn't be trusted and it was more
the right-wing and conservatives who
kind of venerated these agencies in the
name of fighting communism and terrorism
and it was really through the trump
years where everything reversed
because the cia and the fbi became rogue
agencies of the government operating to
subvert and
undermine the elected president to whom
they're supposed to be
answering and so liberals not
necessarily the left but liberals
view the fbi and the cia as their allies
and conservatives finally realized if we
allow these institutions to operate in
the dark
they can undermine our democracy and so
everything is kind of reversed now
where it's the right that's distrustful
of these agencies and liberals who
revere them
well we've got another example of that
for you glenn stick around if you don't
mind because this
next story is one that you've been
following
unlike almost uh the entire american
media julia
julian assange is the wikileaks founder
he's australian
so he's the subject of the queen so he
owes no allegiance to the united states
whatsoever
and if the bloated buffoons of the us
intelligence community are too
incompetent to keep their own secrets
that's hardly his fault but he
embarrassed them so they've spent the
last decade
trying to get him into jail after losing
on extradition a couple of months back
in the westminster magistrates court
they're now appealing by promising that
uh oh don't worry we're not going to
bang him up in the supermax so please
please please
extradite him and we'll handle him with
all the care and attention
we gave to jeffrey epstein julian
assange's father
and brother john and gabriel shipton
join us now from sydney
uh gabriel uh you're julian assange's
uh brother your worries about this
appeal i take it
uh that once he gets to the united
states and he's under the custody of the
federal bureau of prisons
you're actually concerned he's not going
to make it out of there alive whatever
happens
yeah that's right and that's you know
that's why the extradition was rejected
uh back in january and now the
prosecution has given these assurances
that you know julian won't be held in a
in
florence colorado super max prison he
won't be held under sands but
there's uh a caveat in in that and that
um basically they can change their mind
as soon as as soon as julian gets into
the us
that uh you know it's up to the cia
the director of the cia basically to say
uh whether julian ends up in sam's or
which prison he ends up in so there's
really no assurance
at all in this appeal and it's just a
way to keep
uh this court proceeding going and keep
julian in a maximum security prison
in london where he's uh being now third
year in prison there
yeah yeah as you say uh well as we all
say the process
is the punishment here he's lost the
decade of his life
even though he's never been convicted of
anything already
john uh why do you think the u.s
government
is determined to do this if if the
australian government
were trying to put an american in prison
uh for leaking australian
secrets uh americans would be up in arms
about that why do you think the us
government is pursuing this
it's a suitable means to truncate the
first amendment by arresting and
jailing and stewing for well now
12 years a publisher and journalist who
commented upon
the national security information
though just the end full stop
of any comment by any journalist
anywhere in the world including the
united states
on national security matters or any
matter
that the the cia or the
department of justice feel dis-frankly
about
it ruiners of liberty and liberty
is depends solely upon
first amendment three speeches
completely ruined
yeah which ought to be an american issue
i mean they don't have dinosaurs
uh in america like you do in london and
in sydney where there are restrictions
on these things in theory it ought to be
a freer
climate here uh but but gabriel
uh you know when you read the indictment
it's a really
weak case they've got against your
brother and it's a pathetically weak
case
against the foreign national uh that
you're trying to get extradited are you
confident
that the the whichever judge in london
this lands up
in front of uh will actually uh stick
with the decision
of the westminster court in january and
uh and reject this from the americans
yeah i i i think so i mean and the case
it just keeps getting
weaker and weaker uh you know a couple
of weeks ago
one of the key witnesses in the
prosecution's case uh recanted
a lot of their accusations against
julian
uh tortoiseson who was an icelandic man
uh he recanted his accusations that that
formed part of
of the judgment from january 4th uh so
there's this one section of the case uh
the conspiracy to commit computer
intrusion
and that underpins the whole case is
just it's just totally unravelling now
so the case is getting
weaker and weaker uh day by day so
um you know i i expect in in the next
hearings we'll just
hear more about uh you know the lengths
that the
doj has gone to um to
to try and you know game the espionage
act
and and u.s laws to go after julian so
yeah i think eventually this this will
uh have to be dropped well thank you for
joining us from sydney
uh john and gabriel i'm glad you
mentioned that this icelandic witness
who has since recanted because i only
read about that in the icelandic press i
don't remember reading about it in the
new york times or the washington post so
let's go back to
glenn greenwald glenn you'd think this
would be a great freedom of the press
story for the american newspapers uh
and yet it only seems to be of interest
to icelanders and australians and all
kinds of other people
yeah and to fox news which is the only
place that is willing to cover this
and that's the key issue mark remember
for the last five years the u.s media
flamboyantly pranced around
his intrepid defenders of press freedom
when it came to things like
mean tweets from trump about jim acosta
or wolf blitzer
and now you have a prosecution that all
press freedom groups and civil liberties
groups say pose a grave threat to press
freedom if it succeeds
and because it's the biden justice
department pursuing it they're basically
mute if not supportive it's really
disgraceful to watch them do that
yeah and these assurances they're giving
to the english court are completely
worthless as we know in every case from
uh
jeffrey epstein to bill cosby this land
is
rife with uh prosecutor prosecutorial
misconduct
in which they basically tear up
agreements they've entered into as soon
as it suits them
and remember that the democrats
hate julian assange probably more than
any single individual on the planet not
only did he reveal their war crimes
under obama but much worse in their eyes
he did reporting in the 2016 election
that reflected poorly on hillary clinton
they blamed julian assange for helping
trump get elected
do you think they're going to treat him
humanely or justly or fairly
if they get their hands on him no
i do not think so and i tell you this if
i were the relevant cabinet minister in
london
i would whatever the judge says i would
not extradite this guy
to the united states i don't like the
way they're treating
i don't like what happened to jeffrey
epstein they can't keep the most
valuable prisoner in america
alive the bureau of prisons is in is
either incompetent or evil
and you shouldn't be transferring this
guy into its uh
into its tender care thank you so much
for joining on
us on this glenn greenwald and for
sticking around because you're one of
the few people
who's been thank you uh and glenn is
worth reading on this subject as on many
others
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else